let's start first with inflation uh we
saw last week 7.9 percent inflation uh
how accurate is that number in your
opinion
well like i think it's as accurate as
we're going to get but the challenge
with it is this number was supposed to
be going down now for months it was
actually supposed to peak last month but
as we continue to see the inflation
pressures are just continuing to build
and so as a result anywhere you look
across the streets more and more
economists are penciling it in more and
more inflation for this year now at the
end of this year the forecast was
supposed to subside for inflation to
three maybe three and a half percent i
looked at it just yesterday and now the
forecast for inflation is still calling
for it to be at five percent by the end
of the year so that's a challenge and
you know when i look at the inflation
number from last week it's just
everywhere you got 7.9 headline
inflation you got 7.9
food inflation you still got used car
prices that are running at 41 higher
than they were the year before that
there's energy there's shelter and so on
and so forth so it's a real problem is
that it's just we can't point to one
factor that's driving this it's a
multitude of things so um a lot to
unpack there and that's why it's such a
challenge for the fed and frankly it has
to be a challenge for
the governments as well the fed you can
just tackle this alone yeah i think it's
a great point one of the themes that
we've talked about a lot over the last
you know six eight months is just uh if
you don't have good data you can't make
good decisions right just inherently if
you're looking at bad data or flood data
you're going to
lead to bad decision making and you
mentioned shelter and i think that's
probably one of like the biggest
questions that uh people have had as
we've looked at the data which is
shelter is showing you know four or five
percent increase in price over the last
12 months but
rent prices in america are up you know
18 20 percent home prices are up 18 20
and so when we start to think of that as
just one of many many examples across uh
kind of the makeup of the cpi it makes
up 33
of the basket give or take and so like
how do you think about the methodology
that goes into calculating the number
and are people misplaced in their
concerns around how that is being
calculated or do you think actually
maybe we should be looking at that you
know especially in an environment where
there's such high inflation and
everyone's trying to figure out what the
actual numbers are
well i think you bring up a really good
point and that is that your cpi basket
my cpi basket and somebody else's cpi
basket are probably not apples to apples
they're in fact quite different and so
the challenge right now you brought up
shelter and you know i brought up food
and you've got energy transportation
costs and you've got electricity costs
when i look at those four things right
there they account for 94
of spending of the low income consumer
and so that's a real challenge so if
you're having to pay that much more for
shelter uh in food and everything else
that crowds out some of the other
spending so while for example somebody
in the top you know want to or whatever
percent
of their spending bracket they're not
feeling the the pitch from shelter
inflation many many consumers are and so
you know i take your point that the fed
looks at this one cpi indicator and
tries to make a decision based on that
but i do think they also look at a
variety of different measures i think
there's 19 different inflation
indicators they look at and they must be
looking at the segments because
inflation certainly does not hit
everybody to the same degree in the same
proportion the concern is increasingly
hitting more and more consumers take a
look for example at the consumer
confidence index and that is at the
lowest it's been in 10 years which is
kind of surprising right because here we
are venturing out of covet and things
are supposed to be uh getting better but
consumer confidence is at the that 10
10-year low the reason is
inflation is 7.9
wages are not wages are growing at maybe
five or six percent so in real terms
more and more consumers unfortunately
are seeing uh their earnings power go
down yeah we obviously know that whether
you look at official or unofficial
inflation numbers look at wage growth
like all these things like there's a lot
right again maybe 50 of americans that
are being pushed into worse and worse
financial situation uh and so that then
begs the question of like what can the
federal reserve actually do right
historically they basically had these
two tools which is the manipulation of
interest rates and then the expansion or
contraction of the money supply uh how
do you think about
what they can do in these situations uh
and then also like what do you think
they're going to do as we look forward
yeah well the first thing they can do
and they should do is they should get
away from being behind the curve to
actually being proactive about this and
i'll tell you you know in their defense
right i think the fed probably would
have thought about hiking rates back in
the summer of last year and maybe then
again you know in the fall of last year
but the challenge is you had the delta
variant and you know that wreaked havoc
with the supply chains then you had the
omicron variant and they had to pause
for that as well so finally it seems
like they have an opening for them to
finally to catch up if you think about
what's happened is you still have rates
that are pegged at zero inflation at 7.9
percent but the economy had essentially
two months recession it was a very deep
recession back in 2020 but we're well
past that so this is why i say that's
why the fed needs to get back from being
behind the curve because if you look at
a 30 40 year chart of monetary policy
where we are today and inflation there's
never been such a big divergence so they
know this and this is why in the face of
tighter uh financial conditions globally
and the war the tragic war in russia and
ukraine they're still saying they're
going to high grades uh this week at the
meeting this week i think they're
probably going to pencil in six rate
hikes for the rest of the year as well
the reason why they probably have the
latitude to do that is because that's
what the markets expect that's what's
currently priced into the market so that
wouldn't be too shocking and then we get
them i think um a good step forward in
order to not be behind the curve so if
they do that we're going to be looking
at the fed funds rate of 1.8
give or take by the end of the year and
we'll likely get to two and a quarter uh
next year so that's what they're gonna
do um does it
fight inflation does it stop inflation
in its tracks uh i don't think that does
by itself by what i suspect happens over
the course of the next few months to a
year is
monetary policy is going to get more
restrictive and at the same time
commodity prices are still likely to
stay elevated
and that negative um you know wage
pressure is going to start to build so i
do think we're going to see some demand
destruction unfortunately uh come in
sectors of housing for example and some
of the other cyclical parts of the
economy so the fed is going to tighten
demand is going to slow down a little
bit and that's why more more people now
are worried about if a growth slow down
and or recession is on the horizon
so one of the big things that people
keep asking is uh do we have to pick our
poison is this a have inflation uh or
raise rates to address inflation and get
a recession like is that the framework
or the trade-off decision uh or do you
evaluate it some other way could we have
a recession and inflation at the same
time uh could we actually not have a
recession and no inflation like how do
you evaluate what the impact of a hiking
of rates actually ends up being
yeah i think the unfortunate part is in
the next few months we're going to be in
this challenging time period where the
fed is going to be hiking interest rates
into a slowdown and i'm not saying that
the recession is imminent and you know
we're going to plunge right into it but
if you look at historically what the fed
when the fed typically raised interest
rates is when the economy was strong and
potentially getting stronger but because
they haven't done it this time around
they're now going to be hiking into a
global growth slowdown so we look at a
variety of different growth indicators
but for example you look at the
manufacturing indices and the
manufacturing activity has already
peaked late last year and is slowing
down and that's a phenomenon globally
you've got the housing market that's
already slowing down as well and that's
what the fed is hiking into so
you know again it's not that we go from
you know low unemployment rate to five
or six percent over overnight and it's
not that we have negative uh sequential
gdp growth but it's just that growth
sequentially is going to be slower as
the fed hikes rates and hopefully
eventually they get inflation under
control perhaps by the end of the year
so what that means however is for the
markets this is not a positive picture
because
if the economy slows and the cost of
capital goes up then equity markets have
to adjust for that two ways first of all
if you look at the earnings for the s p
500 right now consensus is penciling in
230 bucks for s p 500 earnings for the
next 12 months well does that 230 hold
if the economy starts to slow down
so my suspicion is that it doesn't and
we're going to start to see some of
those downgrades so just over the
weekend we had goldman and several
others it actually did downgrade their
earnings estimates and so when i look at
the time series of earnings estimates
over time we have no now out of a period
where there are more positive upgrades
versus downgrades we're now getting into
that negative territory so that
historically does not bode well for
markets or at least in terms of
generating significant positive
performance and then you get the fed
that is hiking rates meaning the cost of
capital is rising and the multiple
therefore and the s p 500 may also need
to adjust so it's about 18 and a half
times today does it go back to 17 like
it was 17 and a half like it was before
the pandemic that's possible so unless
you have a significant resolution let's
say in russia in ukraine and unless you
have a significant growth catalyst from
somewhere else i just think the returns
for the markets are going to be
subdued if not negative hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time